Dame Kelly thanks so much for joining us
today now you are a national face I
think everyone pretty much in the
country knows who you are you're one of
our most celebrated Olympians you were
the first Britain in over 80 years
nearly a century to win the double the
800 and the 1500 at the 2004 Olympic
Games in Athens
you're pretty much an amazing person I
want to go back if we can to your
childhood and how it all began when did
you realize
that you had this Talent
so it was definitely at school now I
wasn't academic at school so the thing
that made me engage with it was Sport
and I remember my PE teacher kind of
taken me to the side and saying right
you have two options you can be no one
or you can focus on what you're really
good at and that is running but you've
got to believe in yourself and I've
always kind of kept that in my mind over
my career and she sent me off for a
cross-country race and I really did not
want to do it I mean everyone's memories
of cross-conscious school was wet wind
muds you know kind of like I had an afro
hair Airtex Seafood shirt you know kind
of the high knee socks I didn't want to
do it at all but I came second to
against a girl who everyone knew was
really good at our age and it gave me
that far in my belly that I hated losing
and suddenly I was like engaged that was
it sport was my thing so you joined the
Athletic Club when you were 12 and then
you went on to the English schools 1500
meters this is 1983 three you were 13
years old
it was your second season and you won it
yeah so it was my first track season and
it was 1500 meters
I suppose I wasn't really scared at that
time because when you only just starting
anything it's kind of like you've got
nothing else to worry about other than
trying to race and I remember winning
this race standing on the Rostrum and
thinking wow this is like amazing and
then I kept that going throughout my
school career going to English schools
didn't win again until I was 17. I think
because I was inspired by sport by
watching Olympic Games when I was 14
years old but your story is so
fascinating as well because then you
leave school at 16 you then go and work
in a sweet shop and you work as a care a
carer
and then you join the Army
so you are obviously this prestigious
Talent is quite clear you are
exceptionally gifted
but then you stop doing it what what
happened Kelly why did that happen so I
was inspired at age 14 uh to become
Olympic champion after watching
Sebastian Co when the 1500 meters at the
Los Angeles Olympic Games and also to be
in the Army and I think the Army gave me
a sense again of purpose it gave me a
driver and a feeling that I could do
something for myself so I tried to get
into the army over when I was 15 16 17 I
couldn't let you into a 17 and nine
months that season I won my last English
schools Championship as well and it also
became mini Youth Olympic champion and
won a gold medal for my country but I
wanted a career I really did I was
inspired by what I saw you know soldiers
screaming and shouting at other soldiers
going under the scrambonnet and over the
12-foot ball and I was like that is it
that's my life so I ended up trying to
join four years later
you watch the Olympics again
and then you go back to training so what
what check what happened I just find
this story so fascinating because it's
so not linear yeah but you end up at the
you know the apex of the your career so
so 22 you go back to to Athletics yeah
so I'm watching the Olympic Games again
now in my back room which is a room of
your bed and you know that's where you
live and I saw this young girl who used
to race against me from Kent and she was
in this Olympic game she was in the 3000
meters and I just looked there thinking
I mean I know her like this you're like
she's at the Olympic Games and it just
reignited the fire that I'd had in my
belly when I watched it when I was 14
years old and I just I don't know there
was something that came into my head
that that's what I want to do I really
want to be Olympic champion so I was
already competing for the Army but I was
sort of reluctantly doing it because I
loved being a soldier suddenly I find
myself at a world championships for
Great Britain you know and this the
story is actually a bit more fascinating
because
every year as an Elite Sports person you
have a national trials and that National
tiles is to get your selection for that
com that games Commonwealth Europeans
world or Olympics so you have to get
generally in the first two and a
selection time so I rock up to this
National Tarzan 93 been announced as
Corporal homes as I was at the time no
one knew who I was apart from people
that knew me as a junior and somebody
said to me you're just going to chase
these two girls they're going for the
world qualifying time so I chase them
beat them and got the qualifying time
there I was finding myself in this team
so I clearly had a bit of like
competitiveness that I've always had in
my life you know you look back on your
18 year old self that didn't believe you
could be an Olympian was there a part of
you that thought I don't I I don't know
if I can make it I'd rather do this
because I think I can succeed and I
don't know about that I think sport
wasn't a career opportunity really for
you then you know what I mean like it is
now you know and even during my career
it's very amateur you know to actually
Finance your career
um in sport is relying on being one of
the world's best and potentially
sponsorship so at the time wasn't really
a career and now you're doing both
you're training and you're still in the
Army and then at 27
I mean at 27 you go full time uh-huh
and then what happens I mean you go on
in your 30s yeah to win a double
I know it's actually a bit nuts isn't it
that's not the way around you're meant
to do it is it it really is and people
talk to me and the funny thing is is
when I won two gold medals and Athens of
course those that didn't know my career
just suddenly think I'm winning two gold
medals out of nowhere well as an
international athlete for 12 years I'd
won 11 International medals at all of
the top world class I was number
between number one and three in the
world for many many years but of course
the Olympics are the Pinnacle so most
people watch Olympics now that was my
third Olympic game as my first one I
actually did while serving full-time in
the military used to use my leave to go
away and compete I get a bronze so I'm
30 years old and people were like well
you must be retiring now this is the
thing you're going to be retiring and at
34 you win this double yeah did you kind
of in your mind going into that games
were you were you Did you sort of think
it's now or never this is my last shot
at this I think at 34 I thought the
realistic thing was that would probably
be my last games but probably what
people forget is like middle distance
running and women generally were peaking
at 30s yeah anyway late 20s early 30s
and having come back into my sport as a
senior athlete relatively late sort of
at 23 realistically because I missed
that gap between June and Senior I kind
of had that in the bag that was a really
strong female having served in the
military physically and mentally I
suppose in one way
um so yeah just winning you know
I there's a long story and the highs and
lows were huge you know I had many
injuries which affected both my met my
mental and physical health but the one
thing I had and the one thing that kept
me going is I believed I could do it you
know you are a national figure
you are properly famous hugely
successful but there was an underbelly
tool of this wasn't there you've been
struggling with injury and you were
having some mental health issues and you
were self-harming which you then talked
about can you tell me what was going on
underneath this outward success so I
mean there's two two areas the one that
was key and was very public was the fact
that when you're trying to reach an
elite standard
um it's kind of not normal you know what
I mean you're pushing your body and your
mental capacity to the absolute limit
which maybe people don't always
understand you know it became my life it
became everything that I ever thought of
and
because it was who I believed I was at
the time that was me as my identity to
be a sports person every crush or blow
was an injury or illness you know I went
through stress factors ruptured calves
torn Achilles glander fever tonsillitis
damage femoral nerve in my back and
mental health problems
seven years out of my 12 years as an
international athlete and I got to a
point when I was 33 years old which was
a year before the Olympic Games getting
ready for a World Championships where I
had a huge breakdown because the
pressure
expectation of myself to be good one
because I was battling with other things
in my life but two because I really
wanted to be an Olympic champion and I
got to a point where I didn't want to be
here quite frankly but I did you know
you have a battle in your head when half
of you
half of you wants to live and half of
you doesn't what you mean so you felt
suicidal at times yeah absolutely
because you know you push yourself to an
extreme and
my identity at the time was purely about
sport because I didn't feel I had one as
Kelly Holmes I had one as the athlete
Kelly Holmes and so I lived on thriving
to succeed
um so when I basically became a
self-harmer in a training camp in France
because I didn't have an outlet we
didn't really talk about mental health
if you think about 2003 was there much
talk about mental health no openly no so
I didn't even know what that meant I
didn't know what a breakdown meant all I
know is that I was screaming inside and
to release that pain was to hurt myself
it wasn't obviously the best thing I
could have done I could have probably
spoken to someone but I didn't know
because you get fearful of opening up do
you mean that in terms of your career
that because Kelly Holmes because your
identity was Elite athlete if your body
was injured you would feel what's the
point of Kelly Holmes if I can't if I
can't run and win then I'm what's the
point of that's how you fell yeah that's
really tough yeah yeah I really did and
it was hard because all I had in my
mindset was this Olympic games because I
never not just that one Olympic games
but being a world-class Olympic of
Olympian and having an absolute
I don't know where it come from but I
always believed I'll be Olympic champion
and so the prospect of that not
succeeding succeeding yeah was something
you couldn't even forgive yourself for
even though some of the injury problems
are out of your control right they're
out of your control but I also think
that in hindsight it made me who I am
you know now post it I believe in fate
you know before it was just hell but
posted I think well I was meant to go
through this journey you know I was
meant to fight to earn it because I
didn't think I'd win two gold medals I
mean who dreams wakes up and thinks yeah
I can be a double Olympic champion you
know it's not something I dreamed of but
I did it because I remember watching you
like the nation watched you and then for
you to achieve that but then be open
about what was really going on that they
can be outwardly successful but they're
battling issues that aren't being
discussed it's actually quite Brave was
it hard to talk about it or was it
cathartic so I didn't speak about it to
anyone until I retired yeah in 2005
that's what I made my first thought to
biography
the reason being because I actually
never knew how to talk about it so how
when people say to me well how did you
get off of being the lower the low and
win two gold medals the reason why is
because I opened up a lot more to my
team around me about needing help and
support but not about the mental health
side because I still didn't know how to
do that but what I did is bring on board
and say look I know I can do this if I
stay injury free because actually being
the lowest low I couldn't go any lower
with what I'd gone through over my
career so in a way that made me
empowered me to go if I can still win
medals so in my head it drove me to
success so I bought people around me
like you would in any area of life I
bought people who believed in me people
that could keep me healthy and
injury-free keep me motivated I was
still self-harming but there were
moments when it was reminding myself of
reminded myself of what I'm going for
what I've gone through it was like
always a cry for help but it was
lessened because when I wasn't getting
injured I felt better so you you knew
when you were you knew about your
sexuality you said when you were 18 but
you kept that hidden for over three
decades you kept that as a secret
um why did you keep that hidden for so
long
yeah I mean it is a long story but it's
um
I suppose the significance of it is that
Health became an issue in terms of how
you feel about yourself so during covid
we all cope with things very differently
didn't we you know I actually became a
bit of a gym bunny I was doing
everything because I was at home you
know and going out running using the
time that we had to do it yeah I got
covered and because I am someone that
likes to keep active keep fit and then
I'm laying out for three weeks it drove
me insane and it was almost then the
start of me thinking uh about just how I
feel about myself it really kind of had
an impact and it just made me realize
that you know life
life can be so short for so many people
and I just thought to myself do you know
what I want to start living my authentic
life I want to be me and so I decided
that I needed to at some State talk
about the authentic me which is being a
gay woman in public I mean I've always
been it to my friends and family so your
friends and family knew yeah it was just
so it's that public thing that I had to
keep it secret and a lot of it was to do
with my time in the Army but it had an
effect on my mental health
hugely because I thought I don't want to
die with my friends and family saying
what isn't a shame that she just can't
be herself so the impacts on my mental
health were huge
through my whole career but of course I
was able to hide
the talk of mental health through my
sporting career so sport has actually
been my savior for lots of different
reasons when I read about you coming out
you you said you called your Brigadier
basically you're Superior in the Army to
to ask about that now lots of people go
why on Earth were Kelly
need feel the need to do that well put
it in a very short way there was a ban
in the military that stopped people
homosexuality and that band only got
lifted in 2000 I served during that ban
and also there was no talk about
um sexuality in sport either
an international sport you wouldn't you
wouldn't really talk about homosexuality
in sport or in the military so for me I
had these overarching fears in in Broad
in my life for so long that fear is
debilitating you can't just suddenly let
go of fear and the only way I felt that
I could change that was to know there'd
be no repercussions if I publicly said
that I was a gay woman from the Army
even though I have a complex
relationship with the Army because I'm
an honorary Colonel you're
groundbreaking because you were hugely
successful as an Olympian but you talked
about mental health and you're
groundbreaking because you were
successful in the Army and a successful
Sportsman and you talked openly about
sexuality so two things that you battled
with then you spoke about that
that help other people no doubt to open
up I wanted to ask you about this about
whether things are changing you know the
prince and princess of Wales were on
Radio 1 this week or newsbeat talking to
younger people about World Health day
and about how people need toolboxes to
talk about mental health do you think
that things are getting better that
people
are able to talk about there isn't such
a stigma
I do think we're getting there I do
think it all comes with anything about
visibility transparency and seeing
people talking and having that platform
we're safe to talk I think people who
are in the public eye Who start talking
in that realm it makes other people that
have either watched you or be inspired
if you think oh okay it happens to
anybody so I do think there's empowering
people who are very public talking
um to help those that feel isolated or
feel that there's no way they could ever
do it in their life I do think there's a
power to that so I do things changing I
think it changes but it's there's more
that needs to happen and you were
talking about the pandemic and your own
mental health and you know lots of
people I think I think I read two
million people are suffering from long
covert obviously there were huge
challenges of the lockdowns and
isolation
um a big impact on the nation's mental
health and now we've got a cost of
living crisis do you think that we are
or do you worry
that things are going to get worse
because of the sort of two
huge and quite external events that have
kind of Knocked
both sort of nationally knocked us all
but just individuals struggling with
The Fallout of covid struggling with
with current sort of anxiety over how to
make ends meet absolutely so um I've
been working with enough Hotel who have
produced a sort of
index basically and done some
research on the impact of mental and
physical well-being and it shows that
one in three people as mental health has
absolutely got worse over the last 12
months that's a lot that's having a huge
impact on society generally I mean if
you think you mentioned around the cost
of living
around the access to support you know
people are suffering young and old are
suffering and I do think that the
government as a whole have to take some
action to recognize that physical and
mental health goes side by side
so when you're talking about
impacts on society generally people who
are not taking up the jobs and there's
plenty of jobs out there you know why is
this happening you know why is people's
mental health deteriorating
they have to look at this to put well
we're trying to fight for a 10-year
Strat you know a 10-year kind of uh
a proposal so that the government
actually put out like let's say a
legislation to say that they both are
both as important as each other because
I've seen it
so they're saying that the government
guidelines or they have guidelines is
150 minutes of moderate activity per
week moderate activity is just a brisk
walk
Nationwide the average is 65 minutes per
week that means just over 10 minutes a
day we might be bristly walking that's
it
so why are we getting more obese why is
our mental health uh getting really bad
why is there a huge issue with teenage
mental health and suicide because we're
not looking at the importance of being
active and how that correlates with up
here so you would like number one you
think that the government should have a
proper 10-year strategy about trying to
improve the nation's Health yeah and
that needs to be linked to trying to
encourage people to be more active
because we know the link between
physical activity and improve mental
health we'd like the government to
publish a 10-year strategy where it
combines the importance of mental and
physical health well-being being on par
of each other because we know that there
is a really big correlation between both
they are so important so I talk about
in a way that negative side of me
pushing to be an elite athlete and the
pressures it had on my mental health but
I now have to do and be active for my
mental health I have to get out and do
something whether that's in the gym
whether that is just a walk to breathe
to take the stresses and pressures that
I might feel whether that is calling a
mate and saying you fancy going out you
know for a run do you fancy doing even
an online workout Core workout with me
these days I have to do that just to
feel good do you think do you think the
moment the government are letting
people down on Mental Health
you do I do because we're not recognized
as the importance of them going side by
side
I think you know
it's a huge
if you look at the impact of mental
health and how the stats have risen to
those that are suffering and then the
costs on the NHS because they're having
to combat people's mental health
problems why aren't we realizing that
they go side by side your message would
be if you could sort of see you know if
the health secretary's watching this and
she could make one change now
what sort of thing would it be Kelly
would it be more provision for sport in
schools would it be more free access to
gyms for the public what what sort of
practical things would you say please
can you introduce this
um I think firstly
to recognize and publish as joint
strategy for mental and physical health
so that money and you know whatever
money goes to People's Health
it recognizes that it's for mental and
the physical side whatever that may be
I think that
when we're looking at it
the cost of living is huge so if we're
talking about people let's say eating
healthier if the cost of our shopping
let's say is getting so far out there
what are people going to do get the
Quick Fix cheap uh products most of
those aren't that healthy you know
because all the healthy things seem to
be expensive so why don't we look at
just that cost of living in terms of our
health generally definitely the
provision for people to access more
facilities to do more sport if you're
from a disadvantaged area of deprivation
you don't have the means you don't have
the access yet your health is actually
worse off because of that
um of course schools need to prioritize
the need for it to become a priority
that kids do more PE and activity in
school time they're neglecting this
they're putting it on to coaches putting
it on to parents to facilitate it out of
school what does mental health do when
you feel so I can say when I do
something active and I know this I feel
good like I'm more aware I'm kind of
ready to go I feel good in myself same
with young people you know you need to
get them moving make them feel better
about themselves they'll be more
attentive in school just in times of
your journey with mental health and
Sport we saw some examples of that with
very very successful female athletes
over the past year there was Simone
bills the amazing gymnast who had to
pull out of some of the competition in
the Tokyo Olympics we had the tennis
star Naomi Osaka pulling out from the
French Open Over mental health issues
presumably one you could resonate with
how they're feeling and two do you think
it's progress that they're able to do
that rather than keeping it hidden in a
way because both of them were quite
criticized in different ways weren't
they I think it's brilliant that these
young people in sport are having the
confidence and ability to talk about the
effects that they're having as young
people through their mental health
problems
regardless of the fact that they're
world-class athletes are human beings
first and foremost and then we have to
look at that you know people need
support people need access to talk but
they need a safe environment so you need
to be able to open up and express it I
do think that when you get people coming
out who are young and talking about the
impacts as long as there's backed up by
their support mechanisms there's a huge
amount of Charities out there I must say
that anyone that is suffering and
listening to our conversation there's so
many Charities out there that can
support you through this journey because
most of it's about conversation once you
have conversation you open up you get
that support it could be a huge relief
Dome Kelly Holmes thank you for spending
some time it's absolute pleasure to talk
to you today thank you so much thank you